und wenn man schon beiden spricht muss
man natürlich auch über seinen sohn
sprechen besser gesagt seine running
mate denn dadurch haben wir zum ersten
mal eine weibliche vizepräsident und
zwar kanada herres wir wollen uns einmal
bevor wir sie sprechen anschauen wie sie
jetzt die erste reaktion auf diesen sieg
auf twitter gezeigt hat
[Gelächter]
man sieht sie gefühlt ungeschminkt in
jogging sachen irgendwo auf dem feld
stehen das ist echt und pure freude und
wie sehr berührt ein dass auch als frau
also ich weiß über mich aber dieser
vergibt sicht ist es jetzt das erste mal
auch eine frau so ein wohnraum in den
usa einnehmen wird ich glaube das ist
sogar wichtig ist natürlich auch eine
symbolwirkung und sie ist jetzt nicht
gewählt weisende frau ist aber natürlich
ist es toll dass es erst mal eine
geschichte amerikas mit frau oben ist
als vize-präsidentin ich meine die haben
das green gap bei fünfjährigen mädchen
setzte schon einsetzen sich nicht mehr
zutrauen präsidentin oder firmenchefin
werden zu können ist natürlich toll ich
meine zeigt die eine frau dass wir das
grün gelb schließen können die
wirtschaft muss jetzt nachlegen aber von
der symbolwirkung finde es toll was
nicht nur ein bisschen zu denken weil
mein herz ja eigentlich außerhalb von
donald trump für die republikaner
schlägt ich habe etwas angst auch wenn
ich hallo ist sehr sehr bewundere es
sollte so bald mal versterben dass wenn
sie dann an der macht ist es vielleicht
zu links wird in amerika das ist meine
einzige sorge ansonsten ganz toll dass
sie da ist ja da prima dream gibt kann
ich kurz beitrag wird selten persönlich
und auch meine politische sympathien den
usa gilt er den republikanern als partei
von ronald reagan
aber ich kann durchaus sagen als ich das
eben das wahlergebnis meiner tochter
gesagt habe und ihr gesagt habe dass joe
biden präsident wird um das erste mal
eine frau vize präsidentin wird eine
schwarze frau vize präsidentin wird aber
von meiner frau viel um präsidentin wird
ist sie mir vor freude der beiden fand
sie okay aber als ich ihr das erzählt
habe ist mir vor freude in die arme
gesprungen und das ist halt auch immer
etwas was was die wahl des
us-präsidenten ausmacht egal in welchem
politischen lager man sich befindet es
ist immer ein moment in dem er hoffnung
feiert werden und in dem neue
perspektiven möglich werden indem wir
haben das vor acht jahren habe ich es
eine 12 jahre ist das her vor genau
zwölf jahren habe ich es selber erlebt
wie barack obama auf die bühne trat in
chicago und ich stand als reporter vor
dieser bühne als er als er auf die bühne
trat und und die perspektive eröffnet
hat für schwarze in den usa dass sie
präsident werden können und genau diese
diese öffnung einer neuen perspektive
das ist etwas was wir tatsächlich jetzt
auch erleben und ich glaube es gibt
viele frauen oder bis hin zu kleinen
mädchen die genau diesen luftsprung
gerade machen äußerlich oder innerlich
weil sie ihm sehen es ist möglich und es
ist möglich ist immer die botschaft die
von der wahl des us-präsidenten ausgehen
sollte mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren